loading this PL Pawn I like that he
trades off the defender because the
knight from C7 will it's a blunder what
did he play it's a blunder alert oh
Bishop B5 yes oh and he just and I
thought that was a great idea missing
except for oh he missed it and no with
no time on his clock Ali Raza is
now oh my God but wait a minute wait a
minute he does have he does have tricks
what tricks with the a pawn careful C2
and
then Che first hang on Bishop c yeah now
it's still tricky Bishop Bishop C3 you
take the pawn you take on A5 but Black's
got to be better here no no not better
winning uh two Bishops versus the rook
and four pawns but but it's about the
clock now 5
Seconds both players are playing with
their increment oh but what an oh there
goes the F2 F2 pawn and he resigns